chat please
and I'm
going to take a quick look see where
people are joining
Ontario
California not Canada
anybody else
Colombia
Champaign Illinois UK
joining from Kerry today from uh from
Pasadena okay why are you in Kerry Rick
so I'm actually teaching a class uh
today so go around on site with a
company in Perry North Carolina
okay very good
and that's really the mission of
Caltech ctme as to
um
work with companies help to develop
their work viruses
absolutely so we we work with uh
and
Cary North Carolina
Moline Illinois
Sao Paulo Brazil and Pune India
wow
think of all the frequent flyer miles
the trouble is is when you have free
time the last thing you want to do is go
anyplace
well there's always Hawaii right yeah
well actually we're going to Hawaii in
uh in two weeks so
but for that and that'll be a little bit
of business and a little bit of vacation
that's great
which island by the way we're going to
be on on two of them the Big Island
Hawaii and we're also going to be on
Kauai
okay very good
and
so uh the reason I am in two places at
once
I will stop being in two places at once
here
that
I'm going to be sharing my screen from a
second system to make sure we don't have
any glitches
well everybody please let us know what
you're joining us from it's always good
to kind of hear looks like we've got
people from all over the world the UK
and and the US and
and Canada
and
Detroit Michigan great
let's see
okay
we're good here
and
there we go
I knew that we could get there
eventually
all right so thank you all very much for
being here today and uh let's get
started uh we're here to talk about the
data analytics boot camp from Caltech
Center for technology and management
education
and we're extremely fortunate and
honored to have Rick Hefner here who is
the executive director of the
Center
and uh he and I will be talking about
this program along with you so we'll be
asking you for some input
um
I'm sure I'm not going too far too fast
the ground rules are to put the
information to the Q a box
can contact you know chat with us
especially if we ask you a question for
direct response but if you have
questions you want to have covered in
the Q a put those in the Q a box and
zoom uh we are recording the session we
will send a link to you afterward so
that you can review this and we'll be
talking to you about a bonus offer which
you receive for being here today so stay
tuned for that
as I said we're going to be asking you a
few questions through some polls and um
we will also be telling you
a little bit about the field of data
analytics which is the reason why you're
all here with us today and then we'll
talk about how this program with Caltech
is uniquely positioned to help you get
into that field
cover the enrollment steps and that
bonus offer
and Rick and I will take your questions
with that
hoping
should be there okay good
little time lag here
uh we're going to ask this first poll
question in this first poll question is
how much experience do you have in the
workforce so are you currently studying
for your degree or are you working
let us know or keep this open for just
about another 10 seconds
straightforward question
and I will close the poll in five four
three two
one
hit that submit button great
and Rick you can see here that um
eighty percent of our our audience today
are people in the workforce 20 are
students and of the people in the
workforce there's quite a large
contingent of people who have more than
five years of experience so
this is a
fairly seasoned audience yeah and I
think it's good and I think the
important thing to understand is this is
a program kind of for wherever you are
um so if you're still in school you
might be augmenting some degree you
already have
um or you might be changing direction a
little bit maybe maybe doesn't work out
or there's not the job marking you
thought it would be or you might have
some experience
um
um in industry and be able to apply that
um the course can really kind of meet
you wherever you are so we've designed
the the program to be flexible for you
know a wide group of folks great
and can you uh introduce yourself a
little bit uh better for the audience I
I mentioned to your executive director
what does that mean and where do you
where does your background come from
thanks so uh my background is really
industry I've got uh 30 plus years in
Industry working
um in the fields of engineering project
management corporate management I was a
consultant for many years as well so
I've had a chance to work with probably
50 or 60 different companies over my
lifetime
I'm currently the the executive director
for the Caltech Center for technology
management education so the center is
the part of the California Institute of
Technology that does executive and
Professional Training and so we work
with lots of different companies that
are looking to adopt new technologies
they're looking to you know train their
Workforce on various topics including
things like data analytics
um so give a lot of chance to kind of
kind of interface with these companies
um I have been in this role for a little
over 10 years now we have a small staff
and we do about 200 programs a year
similar to this
wonderful yeah I know that the simply
learn works with Caltech on a number of
different programs boot camps and
postgraduate programs and we're
extremely honored by that Association
simply learned as the number one online
boot camp in the world and we specialize
in helping people gain uh digital skills
for the digital economy we've been doing
it for over 13 years now and we've
helped five million people worldwide to
accomplish that kind of upskilling we're
available anywhere that you have an
internet connection which means that
we're
you've helped people in 150 different
countries and as we saw coming into our
chat today we have people coming in from
South America from K from Canada and
across North America so
if I didn't mention your location just
now
um
consider yourself included but we can
provide
programs around the world and through
our unique digital platform which is why
Caltech chose to partner with us and we
said very proud of that
and Stuart our partnership really goes
back for several years now so we've had
a chance as you've mentioned to do
several different programs we'll simply
learn
um it's a great partnership you know
taking the number one online boot camp
company and and
um we like to think of ourselves as the
number one University in the world and
some people have ranked us they are
certainly up near the top but it's a
it's a good combination of forces to
deliver a program like this yeah
I was uh
really kind of uh
surprised and pleased a number of years
ago when the sitcom The Big Bang Theory
came on the air because I I couldn't
have thought of a better place for them
to situate a story about really
brilliant people
um than Caltech because it's one of the
greatest concentrations of really
Brilliant Minds in the world so
I've always
been
big fan of the institution
we're going to talk about careers in
data analytics so it's kind of just to
set the scene data is really what drives
our digital economy today especially in
the wake of the pandemic where
so much of our Lives went into online
working yeah
online
interactions with uh the people we buy
from the people we sell to the people we
interact with
so much of our lives are done on on the
webinar our mobile devices
so that's really created a huge
[Music]
um
both problem and opportunity for
companies right Rick
you know it really has Stuart
um it's just the the growth in this
field is amazing there's very difficult
to name any company that really doesn't
run on data and you have
companies from Health Care to Consumer
products to you know uh technology
investment even research companies
everybody can use their data to optimize
their business to to help them do better
financially and and the growth of this
industry is really outstripped uh the
University's ability to to put out
people with these skills which is one of
the reasons why we just started a few
years ago to start this program
have you have you seen some pretty
interesting um
case studies from some of the companies
you work with
I I have it it's interesting so
um you know we work with a lot of
Technology driven companies
um companies like Boeing for example
um they found that by using data about
the status of their planes for example
they can reduce their maintenance costs
by a significant amount and now it's
just become part of their business
um was a program they started uh maybe
eight or ten years ago in Earnest and
the the deeper they get into using these
tools the better we work with another
several companies that are using this
and kind of marketing area to understand
the marketplace in order to stand sales
we are I think a special growth has been
in healthcare
um Healthcare is consuming a large and
larger part of the economy lately and so
we're working with several different
companies who are looking at
patient records
looking even at diagnostic results and
being able to you know predict treatment
programs and the effectivity of them
Based on data so I just think the sky's
the limit and especially you see a lot
of brand new applications now with all
the surge in artificial intelligence and
machine learning
we're finding even more creative things
to do with the data that we have
yeah and and insights from data I mean
the data itself is is
uh just data until you
extract insights and meaning from it so
that's that's really what the the whole
purpose of data analytics is for people
to be able to recognize what patterns
apply in any given set of data apply
those techniques and pull out the
insights and then be able to communicate
them
it's kind of like what that little
graphic is showing is that the data has
to be turned into something that people
can understand that's a big part of the
field right right
yeah and I think you know we've we've
always had data companies have run on
data what they've what we've now
realized is
um the data doesn't have to be super
clean it doesn't have to be very
consistent we can still extract we have
ways of cleaning things up we have ways
of acquiring it
um the whole internet of things movement
means there's just lots more data that's
that's available these days most of us
talk to things like uh Siri or Alexa and
you know find out things that you know
when a store might be open or what a
consumer rating was on a product and
stuff that's all this data that exists
out in the web and the amount of data
that's accessible publicly has just
expanded by you know exponentially that
said companies are recognizing that
there's there's money to be made from
Big Data so there's lots of investment
on it at the same time the cost of of
retaining data has really gone down so
data storage has become much much
cheaper which I think again is an isn't
a whole enabler for the for the growth
in this field
yeah it's a it's amazing that you don't
have to build a data center because you
can acquire a data center
um on the fly as you need it and only
when you need it through cloud services
so it's it's made this the underlying
platforms more accessible across all
Industries and then
people who want to enter the field need
to have
kind of a basic
toolkit right so this is a there's some
of the things that people need to be
able to understand or accomplish or work
with in order to be in this field
absolutely and you know when we talk
about skill sets it
part of the the complexity is there's so
many different data analyst positions
you could have could be the type of
company or the type of Industry you're
looking at could be the type of data
you're looking at
um could be your focus on the data so we
really did need a bunch of different
people with different skills
um different there are some Basics that
pretty much every data anal panelist
needs to know but then as you get on the
job and you become familiar with other
tools you build on this kind of
foundation
so when we built this course we really
sort of thought what are what's the sort
of the fundamental math the fundamental
computer science and really the key
tools like like Python and Tableau and
AWS that 90 of the industry is going to
use and most people are going to gonna
want to do
um that said people are doing you know
statistical analysis with tools as
simple as Excel these days and and there
have been incredible capabilities with
Excel with uh even small add-ons for
Excel that you know people get at low
cost and run in small operations so
anything from sort of family businesses
all up to the the biggest corporations
in the world can use people with these
kind of skills yeah and that's a that's
that's a great aspect of the program
because Excel is ubiquitous and
being prepared to work on that platform
along with you know more sophisticated
platforms gives you the maximum
flexibility
let me talk about some statistics here
about the growth of jobs in this field
dice.com which is the Techno technology
career site says that there's a 28
annual job growth
jobs in data analytics
if you're a data analyst at the starting
level and moving up within that job
description you can move up to a
six-figure salary but if you're a senior
data analyst as you gain more
um
experience and more skills
you can increase your salary potential
significantly so
this is uh I mean Rick would you comment
on this as a as a career field for for
people what what are the kinds of
potentials that well I think it's really
difficult to think of any field where
we're anticipating 28 job growth by
2026. I know some people may have chosen
Fields you know early in their career or
you know when they started their studies
that maybe now are sort of going away
and some technologies like artificial
intelligence machine learning are really
driving some some careers out of
existence
um the nice thing about that about data
analytics is
uh it feels like Ai and machine learning
become enablers and so it just really
increases demand for data analysts so
um it's a good career to enter in it's a
good career to transition from if you've
been in a technical field
um my own daughter is pursuing a career
in data analysis right now so
um I I think the sky's the limited it
it's tough for me to think of another
career that I would suggest to a to a
young person or a mid mid-career person
looking to change that would be better
than data analytics uh I just won't see
this kind of growth anyplace else and
it's something that's going to continue
on
data analysis are going to be needed in
this kind of kind of amount one things
to point out too is what's driving the
salaries because the the absence of
people in the marketplace the demand is
just outstripping people and that
continues to put salary professional so
companies are having to play pay very
high amounts for starting data analysts
and they're having to pay even bigger
amounts for people with experience that
that can mentor other individuals at
their organization
one other aspect of the career path is
that the
skills that you gain in data analytics
can serve you as you move into other
areas of uh business management so if
you you have Ambitions to move into
financial management marketing
management operations management having
the ability to understand
the data and
what people are telling you about your
operations
that's a really strong force multiplier
for you we took a look at Glassdoor and
just kind of kicked off the top
companies listed under
category of data analytics and people
hiring data analytics and you can see
it's
you know it ranges across a broad
spectrum from Amazon to Kaiser
Permanente in healthcare to Wells Fargo
and in banking and JPMorgan Chase and
banking Financial Services like
Accenture and Consulting of course
Google
but you would see examples from pretty
much every industry across the board
wouldn't you
you would and and you'd see the Muslims
data analyst you also just see other
jobs that are really analyst positions
just have the word data in the title
sometimes you see this listed as data
science
um so
um
to me I'm seeing the most growth in
health care and in the banking Community
obviously both Fields have lots of data
both Fields have important outcomes we
need to make sense of the data as you
said before we need to get insights from
all this information and you see that
but the surprising thing is the growth
and sales and marketing organizations
people like Amazon
you know when Amazon looks at something
you know that you're you're considering
buying and makes other recommendations
for you that's all data and they have uh
they've used data analytics to say gee
the people that buy these products are
probably interested in these products
and here's the kind of white timeline to
present that concept so we've all been
on social media or something and seen
recommendations that line up with
something we were looking at before you
know so we were studying uh a trip to
Hawaii maybe in now we see books and and
material about Hawaii our feeds so
that's all that's all driven by data
yeah well since we've talked about
Hawaii mentioning your upcoming vacation
to Hawaii uh today you're probably your
phone has heard that and you'll you'll
see some more more recommendations uh
well well and and
you know I use one of the Consolidated
websites that basically looked across
the the all the airline sites to find
the best airline deal and the best hotel
deal and you know we've come to think of
that just part of it that
the the ability to bring large data sets
and an understanding of those to the
consumer is driving a lot of this
economy so big companies like Google and
Amazon need lots of data analysts to
build these kind of systems that are
customer facing and as you mentioned
smaller companies do as well so it's if
your taste is not to work for a giant
corporation uh this is still a great
field for you to work for midsize to
smaller companies as well so I think the
other thing too is it's a field that you
can do remotely so a lot of data's data
analysis work out of their home
and access their data through you know
the internet so
um it's not something that I have to be
at an office from or I have to be on
site for
yeah that's that's a wonderful change to
Lifestyle that we've experienced some
people have adapted to it very well
since the pandemic other people prefer
to be in the office and the nice thing
is that
people are getting that choice now but
it's I prefer for example working from
home
um the size of the group I work with and
where the local office is it's uh much
more convenient so uh here's a poll
about
what's prevented you in the audience
you're all here because you're
interested in this career area
qualification certification in it but
why haven't you done it so far what are
the things that that you've objected to
about other programs
and we'll just leave this open for
another uh about 10 seconds or so you
can of course choose more than one
answer
I will close the poll in five four three
two one
interesting result there's the one
answer that uh
leader of the pack
most people responding said they're
concerned with getting a program that
will give them practical exposure
experience that they can use to show off
their new skills
to the current employer or future
employer and say
here's examples of the work I did and
then the other three are right even in
terms of concern having a program that's
comprehensive covers all of the skill
areas that we talked about
finding a program that isn't just
pre-recorded videos
and finding a program that fits in your
work schedule so that you don't have to
interrupt your career
in order to become qualified
so
excuse me
but Rick when you look at this program
and how does it line up with these you
know the kind of qualities of the ninth
yield program
you know it's great to get some kind of
validation of these kind of concerns
because I think this is exactly how we
tried to put this program together was
to address these ideas we wanted a
program that was comprehensive but we
wanted it to be practical the real goal
in this program is to is to train
somebody to get a job we want that this
number one gave you the skills number
two give you a resume give you a
portfolio that you could take to a to
somebody you know lots of Industry you
said to him I'd love to have somebody
some experience
you're going to be working on practical
case studies during this program taken
from real life examples so you know you
you interview a Healthcare Company you
could say look look at the healthcare
case studying that I did as part of the
the simply learn Caltech curriculum I've
worked on this kind of system I
understand some of the challenges that
I'm going to going to see so it's it's
build that skills gave you something
impressive to put on your resume
and you know it's a different learning
environment than it was today and people
have these kind of time pressures and
scheduled pressures and we want to
specifically have a program that
somebody who currently has a job can can
use to change positions maybe get into a
a
career with more growth and more more
potential or more satisfying or to give
them that flexibility to to stay at home
um and so
the course
um is a mix we've got live instructors
live remote so like you say any from any
place you sit you listen to the
instructors you ask questions you hear
questions asked by your your classmates
um that's all good they're also recorded
so you can you can watch them so if you
couldn't make this site you can go back
and listen to it so you've got kind of
The Best of Both Worlds and that that
was design uh purposely and then we want
it flexible so it would fit people's
lifestyle you're coming to this from
different maybe you've got a full-time
job and you're going to have to do this
on nights and weekends right
um maybe you're you're you're not
working right now and you can really go
as fast as you want to want it and get
out as quickly as possible so we've
built that flexibility into the program
so it's good to hear that these are the
concerns that people have
um
we we built this program kind of looking
at other programs and some of the con
um complaints and constraints that we
heard from from our other students
and and that's also you know a lot of
the reasoning and logic behind how
simply learn constructed the platform
through which the program's delivered um
and one thing to point out is that when
we talk about the different tools things
like python or
um
learning Tableau or those types of
things
it's not just a matter of being exposed
to them or watching video tutorials
about them this platform lets you access
those tools and use them in actual
development projects that are done on
the platform in a virtual machine that's
assigned to you so you don't have to
acquire
separate Hardware or software to do the
work but you get to do the work Hands-On
and when you finish you'll be able to
say yes I'm skilled in for example
Tableau techniques because here are
examples of what I've done with it
I think yeah I think the other thing to
distress is that you're learning from
industry experts people who are
currently working in the field the
simply learned instructors the Caltech
instructors are not academicians they're
people that are practicing data
analytics in their day-to-day job
they're teaching as a part-time job
because they love teaching and because
they want to share what they've learned
in Industry so these are practical
people you're going to connect with
people that can help you get a job some
programs are about learning some people
are about preparing you to get a job we
really try to do to make this program do
both yeah that's one of the things that
makes this
really unique in the environment is that
you have both aspects of it within six
months and and we say you want to commit
10 to 15 hours a week because there's
about eight hours a week during the
courses that have live classes eight
hours of live instruction each week
during those courses Plus in
preparation or homework you do
um not all the courses have a live
component some of them are self-study
and self-paced so
uh again we say about an average of 10
to 15 hours a week over six months Rick
when when some people look at that
number and say you know in six months
six you know that's
no not that many
um
hours compared to any other type of uh
academic well I really learned this
subject
if I only
buy myself for 10 or 15 hours a week or
six months
yeah it's a good question I think it
first of all you're not by yourself
you've got connection to instructors you
can ask questions you can reach out our
instructors are anxious to share what
they've learned so they can always
follow up with this
um but again we we've got this so
focused on developing job ready skills
you're going to walk out of here and and
be able to make your case to an employer
that that I have this degree from
Caltech and was between this certificate
from Caltech and simply learn
I've got this experience working on
these case studies I can I have
experience in working with the common
tools that I use in the industry I'm
going to be able to start day one you
know making a contribution to your
organization
that said we're always happy to help
people extend and make connections with
other fields expand in your area look at
other case studies we have a rich Legacy
of other things that are applicable
maybe you're in healthcare maybe you'd
like to see two or three applications of
how this is done in healthcare maybe
you'd like to be introduced to somebody
who's working in the healthcare field
who can go into more depth or help you
find that job or tell you what a typical
day in the life of a data analyst in a
large company like Kaiser Permanente
feels like we can make those kind of
connections so yeah it's a compromise
you could go off to a university and
spend you know two to four years getting
a degree and data analysis
um you'd certainly spend more time you
could get into more depth in some of
these topics but those kind of degree
programs just aren't practical for a lot
of people and so we we've tried to
to to develop really a professional
training program that that's going to
meet the need
thank you
yeah the the result is that you receive
a certificate
from Caltech ctme that
puts their name and reputation behind
the training so when you present this
that means that Rick and his team can
say
yes you have obtained the skills
attained this level of uh proficiency
that the program provides you have
Capstone project that we'll we'll
mention in addition to the many other
projects that you complete during the
program
you have ability to be in the Caltech
ctme online
alumni program for people who have taken
programs from ctme
you go to an online convocation that you
can invite your friends and family to so
see your uh name being recognized by
Rick and by the simply learning team for
your accomplishment and we'll also talk
about the career assistance that we
provide to help you find a job after you
get your certificate so this is a a
pretty comprehensive package of benefits
say Rick yeah absolutely so you know
first of all I think a certificate with
Caltech is that we learned his name on
it means quite a bit in industry and and
so that's going to be impressive but but
more than that when you go to your job
interview for your data analytics
position you need to be able to make the
case and and so to me I think your
portfolio is very important you're going
to have some practical capstones that
are going to resonate with employers
again our Focus was give people job
ready skills we're used to dealing with
a professional in the workforce so we
know that what employers are looking for
we work with the companies that are
hiring these people so the portfolio is
a big thing
um the the circle membership the alumni
membership that's a that's a perk
um so we'll we'll we are trying to have
some quarterly events on campus we're
trying to have some of their online
events to supplement that but
um you know we're looking forward to
having people come out to Pasadena if
that's practical and you know tour
through some of the robotics lab talk to
some of the leading researchers that are
doing work in data analytics and and get
a sense of where that's going
um
and then I think the career assistance
is important
one of the ways we measure the success
of this program is how many of our
graduates find a job in this field
within the six months or six months of
graduation
some people use this to change
Industries some people use this to stay
in their industry leverage what they
already know about their domain and and
seek it in a different position some
people stay within the same company and
just just use this learning to augment
what they're already doing so a lot of a
lot of use cases here but we really try
to think about this and and I think you
end up with a nice package it's not a
cheap program but if you look at what it
would cost for a Caltech degree it would
be you know significant amount I think
our currently our tuition is something
like 50 000 a year so this is a very
minor investment to get some job ready
skills comparatively speaking yes it is
and that leads into an opportunity for
you to tell people you know I I
mentioned kind of the the
the pop culture aspect of uh The Big
Bang Theory but really that that builds
on the fact that Caltech
is known worldwide as a premier
institution can you tell us more about
that in the ctme relates to that
yeah so we've been around for a long
time we have I think something like 59
Noble
laureates at this point
um consistently ranking at the top of
the whatever ranking different different
organizations and magazines do wanking
but one of the way reasons they rank us
so high is it is a very elite place we
we have a huge endowment we have a
number of companies that are doing
research with us
um we have a lot of academic freedom at
Caltech for me The Prestige of the
University just means I get to work with
some of the leading companies in the
world
um and all over the world and that's
that's really nice
we wouldn't put our name on this program
if it wasn't a high quality program we
didn't think it was proactivable
um Caltech guards its reputation very
seriously and so
um we monitor the program to make sure
that first of all of the instructors are
top-notch instructors and top-notch
people in their field
um we we specifically recruit in the
higher industry leaders that we know who
can talk about industry Trends Advanced
topics and other things through the
Caltech master classes that we do as
part of the program
so that
um when you when you come out of this
you're going to have something that is
going to be impressive it's going to get
your foot in the door to somebody it's
going to put your resume ahead of
somebody else
um Caltech takes its its reputation very
seriously so we stay on top of any any
issues or challenges that we have to
make sure this is a this is a super
quality program is it as rigorous as
going to Caltech
you know caltech's undergraduate and
graduate programs have more of an
academic flavor so this this is still a
very impressive program that's aimed at
at specifically job Seekers
and the the fascinating thing to me
about the boot camp programs with
Caltech is that they're they're aimed to
be for a very broad audience of
pretty much anyone who has the drive the
determination and the aptitude take on
the different subject areas so if you
have a drive
to uh solve problems with data if you
kind of person who's really interested
in patterns and puzzles
um and how data can be used to solve the
big problems facing the world or the
smaller problems facing
individual businesses
this is a program for you you only have
to have a high school diploma and be at
least 18 years of age for the academic
qualification you don't have to have
prior work experience and you don't
really have to have prior knowledge of
programming or technology beyond that
which we all have in terms of
being able to use the web and all of us
are here on Zoom so that pretty much
says that you're familiar with your way
around a keyboard and a laptop so that
gives you kind of the the Baseline that
you need long as you have the
determination and the desire in order to
apply yourself for the six months of the
program
that had I described that fairly Rick I
I think you have and I think that's
probably the number one question I get
Stuart is oh my God it's a program from
Caltech you know I haven't been
programming for 10 years you know am I
going to feel swamped or you know
um we don't assume anything
um except except some technical aptitude
and if you apply yourself
nothing is sort of Beyond learning that
said if you've got technical programming
you're going to build from there and
you're going to you know address a more
a deeper question so the reason senior
data analysts are senior is because they
often have you know a more a stronger
math or computer science underpinning
but don't let you that worry the demand
is so great right now for data analysts
that if you just have a basic ability to
work with computer software you have a
basic understanding of math and and we
can teach you the the details that you
need to be a data analyst working with
you know other mentors and supervisors
on some of the tough while there's so
much demand industry right now for all
levels entry intermediate Advanced
um so don't let
the lack of a technical background or
experience being being limited for you
um I have I have I have not come into
contact with any student in any of the
offerings we've ever done that I said
hey the material was too hard when I
couldn't pick it up
no it's it's it's it's fed to you in a
way that
um makes it practical gives you a chance
to use it
um it's probably different than when I
was doing data analysis you know as a
young engineer you had to have a big
statistics background you had to do
everything by hand the the tools that we
teach you like like python AWS uh
Tableau Etc handle a lot of that heavy
lifting for you so
um the basics of how to use those tools
is something we can teach
and the the fact that it's wide open to
people without a technical background
also means it's suitable for making a
career pivot out of a non-technical area
if you want to add these skills as part
of your tool set to pursue your career
in a non-technical area or if you want
to move out of that non-technical area
into data analytics
we'll talk about how the program
prepares you
and this is where we get into the
comprehensive curriculum so the way we
like to visualize that is as a a
staircase where start with an induction
session which is pretty much you know a
couple of hours online to get oriented
to how to use the Learning System what
your curriculum is going to be like uh
the
administrative
tools that you have getting help and
support all of that type of thing and
then
um
the first module is Excel and that's a
deliberate choice right right
yeah I want to start you a basic most
people understand it Excel but concepts
are simple and a lot of mom and pop
shops use Excel for doing quite a bit of
data analysts sales analysis and
projections you know warranty work
um you can do a surprisingly large
amount of things sit with with simple
Excel
um
and then moving into presentations this
is where you start looking at the
communication aspect of
learn things by doing the analysis with
the statistical methods and analytics
tools you've gotten some insights but
how do you communicate those to the
other people in your organization who
need to know what you've learned and so
building
visualizations presentations telling the
story with the data
the next module there
from from that you move into SQL which
is uh
important for understanding
the raw material you're going to be
using which is data right
that's right that's right so it's just a
basic foundational and you're also
learning in a practical way how to apply
some of the the basic concepts of data
manipulation
from That You Learn Python so we don't
assume that you come into the program
knowing how to code in Python
um Learn Python But You Learn Python in
the context of
how it's used and what libraries are
used to help you with uh manipulating
the data analyzing the data creating um
the story with the data so all of that
it's a applied python learning
and then
deeper into advanced visualization tools
and and dashboards and that type of
thing with tableau
Tableau is a program that allows you to
take this uh
set of insights that have
Bindings that you've gotten from other
tools and turn them into
attractive understandable visualizations
and presentations right Rick
yeah absolutely and I think that's
important when people say well why do
you do cover presentations
but data analysis is about making
actionable
uh insights out of data so every data
analyst has to be able to present
the information to groups what insights
Can We Gather
um you know how do we know these
insights are valid that sort of thing so
all of this is is doing that and and
tools like SQL python Tableau AWS
commonly used tools and Industry so
being able to present the results of
those tools to to management to
stakeholders that that's a key part of
this
the last module before the Capstone is
data analytics on the cloud AWS being
the example cloud provider that Caltech
chose for the program but the the cloud
environment is very different from as
you said when you were a young engineer
and you'd load all the data onto one
system whether it was your mini computer
or your desktop
and do all the analytics but today it's
a very different environment isn't it
yeah absolutely you know uh data's
everywhere I would say it's ubiquitous
right we can you know you you didn't
know where you're acquiring data from
but you don't have to pull it all
together into a central repository like
you used to and so a lot of times it's
using using learning how to use these
distributed databases you know maybe
you're you're working with a worldwide
organization that has sales points all
over the place or warranty offices all
over there where and we're all Gathering
all of this data in real time trying to
make sense of it trying to predict
patterns trying to see emerging the
financial Market is you know replete
with you know Financial opportunities
that appear and are gone a day later so
timeliness and the ability to access
data off the cloud is just a critical
skill nowadays
and then finally you tie this all
together with the the data analytics
boot camp Capstone so the Capstone
project is where you get to choose from
several different uh industry domains uh
one that most interests you
get a challenge of a industry aligned
problem and then
you get to work with an instructor over
a three or four week period how does
that process work
so so people will typically choose a
Capstone that you know fits
um their interests you know so this
might be Health Care this might be
um product development this might be
marketing this might be Financial
there's lots of choices to pick from you
could even custom build one hey I'm want
to do something and you know and in this
particular business area we love to get
involved in kind of those and move them
um and then you get you get advice from
the instructor okay here's common
problems here here's things that people
like to do here are the big challenges
that that are facing that industry and
then you can kind of self-select what
you want to do and and my advice is
always make this Capstone project
something that's going to be job facing
make it something that when you explain
what you've done on this Capstone to
your own to a potential employer they go
hey that's what we do that sounds like
you know the sort of challenges that we
have in our business and you get a
chance to back to skills so you've got
an artist who wanted to get hired by a a
company would would have a portfolio of
work to show here's what here's what I
can do or a designer would same thing
you want a portfolio that you can show
to a potential employer that they're
going to resonate with and so you choose
that you get help with that and then
it's really the sky's the limit some
people do a minimal job and get through
it and they're anxious to get out of the
program some people were only you know
take on a project that's a a problem for
their current employer and that they can
do as part of work that they're already
doing at the company they work in so
there's a there's a whole spectrum of
things you can do but it should always
be something that is going to
demonstrate your capabilities That's
Unique often
somebody coming out of a more
traditional University program doesn't
necessarily have
um you know they have kind of book
examples they're not going to
necessarily resonate with an employer
yeah
so along the way you know we've talked
about various tools and these are some
of them
but when we as I mentioned before
when you're taking the courses you will
have Labs exercises and course end
projects
that will require you to fire up these
tools on the Learning System
and
apply them to solve the problem or to do
the lab so you'll end up with
smaller examples that'll also add to
your portfolio right Rick this is just a
kind of a portfolio that has the
Capstone and a lot of supporting
materials behind it yeah and I've seen
some questions chat about other tools
like power bi and other power apps Etc
we try to expose you to everything
that's been really accused out there
these are the tools that we really
concentrate on because these tools are
being used by by everyone but you will
get exposure to to pretty much every
tool used in industry and and even
things like Excel that people do so uh
yeah
um you you'll get exposures to all these
Tools Plus more
we've just had a good explanation of the
Capstone project so I won't spend time
on this slide but just to remind you
that this is something that builds your
portfolio something that you can
showcase to your potential future
employer or to your current employer
and the the other thing I'll mention
about the learning management system and
how simply learn administers it that we
provide
um in addition to
Caltech has provided for the program we
provide a program manager who works
directly with Rick and other Caltech
Personnel to make sure that we're
administering the program delivering it
properly if you join on a particular
date you become part of what's called a
cohort and
you and your fellow uh students from
that particular cohort will have
somebody assigned to be their success
manager
you'll have of course the interaction
and support of your instructors you'll
have a curriculum and the resources and
the
pre-recorded materials the data sets the
code examples
ebooks all of the material that goes
along with the instruction
and you also have the support of your
teams and peers
one of the cool things about the program
is that you have the ability to refer to
the community of people who are learning
with you and your instructors so Rick do
you have a comment on how that works on
how the the community works
yeah you're tying in with a number of
people when you're part of the program
so during the life of the program you're
going to come into contact with some
simply learned instructors and with some
Caltech Master instructors these are
people typically out in the community
when as you approach the end of the
program you're going to get tied in with
the the job placement services and also
that's something that instructors can
help with you know in terms of finding
the right location for you understanding
the differences between different jobs
in the marketplace
Etc so that's all part of it but then it
continues after graduation you're part
of the Caltech CTE Circle that's that's
our alumni group and you can communicate
without past alumni in terms of where
are they finding jobs
where are some interesting things gosh
I'm thinking of working for company X is
anybody got any feedback about that
company whether that's a good place to
work or not so you're tying into a
community of data analysts we also get a
lot of inquiries from companies hey Gee
we we really need to to hire a big slug
of people you know we we know this
Caltech data
program is strong can you suggest some
graduates for us so you're tying into a
group that's industry facing that can
Aid you in a variety of ways depending
on your needs
okay thank you for that
um I will mention the learning
environment
um The Learning environment allows you
to log on manage your curriculum see
what classes are available to you where
you are in the sequence of courses uh it
gives you the live virtual classroom and
assessments that you do online along
with your labs and projects it's the
environment where you do your Capstone
project and again it's keeping track of
everything you're doing and telling you
what needs to be done next in order to
get to the next step so as you complete
each course you unlock a certificate for
that course and when you finally
complete the Capstone and it's evaluated
you get your final certificate delivered
to you and along with that are the
support tools that we talked about so
you have a 24x7 help desk for any
questions about the use of the platform
but you also have
social Community feature that allows you
to ask questions to your peers and to
your instructors
all of that is on the learning
environment
and
Rick Hefner needs no further
introduction as we've gotten to know him
over the last 45 minutes
um but he again uh oversees the program
so this is really a Caltech program
delivered by simplywear
yeah and I and and I want to just
encourage people if they have questions
if they want to reach out I'm more than
happy to answer questions I I love
connections and I especially love
hearing from past graduates who use this
course to leverage a you know an
exciting position or a career change
um those are the things that makes thy
day we're involved in education to help
people change their lives and so when we
hear about about these I always love
doing that are always help assisting
somebody in those kind of Life Changes
because maybe that's really giving back
the community was really what it's all
about at this point
there we go
so let's talk a little bit about some
learner outcomes and
you know what if people
achieve from the program first
describing
um
typical cohorts so you look at who where
people have entered the program from and
again this is generally speaking for
working professionals so you have people
coming in from the information
technology area certainly but also you
see a lot of people from Banking and
Financial Services
from Pharma and Health Care from retail
and from a wide range of other
Industries see examples of people who
have joined the program from companies
while working at companies like
Amazon or Fidelity Investments or
Vodafone or Nvidia so you can see it
goes across
a wide spectrum and these are people
that you know if you're in a cohort with
people from various companies that in
itself is a networking opportunity isn't
it rick
yeah absolutely and and I mean these
this list of companies that people have
come to us from social list of companies
that people hire graduates from so
people that the companies that that suck
up our graduates uh and and in good
numbers so
um and many more you could probably put
you know several dozen other companies
around here in terms of where the hiring
company it is really Broad and it's
interesting to see kind of the
statistics you have them left here
because that kind of fits my
understanding of the the needs so we're
representative of the rest of the
community and the and the need for for
data analysts out there yeah yeah I do
want to mention the list of companies on
the right is not exhausted by any means
yeah we talked about the career assist
service and so simply learn provides for
people in the U.S specifically for this
program
um and I apologize that we're not
currently making it available for people
outside of the US but this is a part of
the program that extends for six months
after your certificate is issued
gives you access to Services through our
partner Talent Inc including a job
portal that is uh exclusive and
confidential for them so you can take a
look at jobs that are listed through
that area you also get two really
valuable services having to do with
resume review and rewrite
um no
resumes don't go to people right away do
they Rick basically go did you go to the
machines first yeah unfortunately one of
the areas for for some job that
frustrates some job Seekers is that data
analytics is used now for resume review
you know typically I recently had a job
posting in my organization I had 101
resumes but in the first couple weeks so
obviously humans can't necessarily look
at all those in a timely fashion so most
employers now use data analytics tools
to look through resumes capture keywords
fit against jobs that sort of thing so
we'll help you in terms of writing a
resume to make sure that you're not
getting getting overlooked in that in
that Crunch and then you know maybe
you'll end up working for a company that
does this kind of resume work right and
then the resume will still look
attractive once it gets past the
a I bought and gets to a human
desktopper or screen so that's really
the art that comes in with the resume
rewrite is making it fit both the
automated process and the human element
the same thing with the the interview
Services you have to clear so many
interviews in order to get a promotion
or a new job with you know everything
from the phone screen with the recruiter
to the technical interviews with the
people you're going to be working with
and you're
prospective supervisor and then the you
know
interviews with management about it in
your bit with the culture and your work
ethic so these are all different sides
of you you have to be able to put
forward so it's great to be able to
practice each of those with a live
interviewer so I can't tell you how many
people I've helped Stuart with with you
know finding jobs and careers and things
like that and you know
naively people think it's about somebody
finding you it's really about you not
getting lost in the shuffle yeah um and
so you want to write your resume in a
way that doesn't get screened out by
these AI Bots and you want to to come to
the interview ready to impress
somebody's going to hire you because
they're excited about working with you
because they've got skills that have
proven skills that are gonna that they
know are going to work on the job nobody
wants to take a chance of an unproven
person so you got to come to that
interview ready to explain
um how you are going to contribute to
the organization that's where an
interview coach can really you know
somebody in your field can say hey let
me strengthen the answer to this
question for you let me help you with
wider askings let me tell you the top 10
questions they're going to answer with
you and what good answers were those to
look like so just being aware of that
being aware of what the interviews are
looking for a lot of the people that are
Masters instructors and our courses are
hiring managers in their companies so
they know what they're looking for in
data analytics they bring those kind of
skills to the course but also they can
help you in making sure that you're
going to do well in the interview
so we we flashed it a little bit earlier
the the program fee in total is eight
thousand dollars uh that's the U.S
pricing if you are in a different
location you may be able to see
different pricing for your local region
and I will share with you the website
but you can also contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net to ask that question
we do provide equal monthly installment
financing
um for this program as low as 704
dollars a month
which I believe makes it a 12-month
financing program and
to your bonus offer for attending today
if you join our next cohort
uh your thank you for being with us with
Rick and me today is
500 off of the program fees so that's a
pretty attractive
uh gift from us for you being here with
us today
um and I would be remiss if I didn't
remind you that you could also ask your
employer if they have tuition
reimbursement programs that can help you
with Summer all of the cost
and I think that's important Stuart
especially if you're developing skills
that your employer needs and very most
employers need data analysts
um they're they're quite often there's a
tuition reimbursement program that's
going to pick up these costs we have a
number of students that whose uh costs
are being paid affordable by their
employer
so we move next
quick question then for you about
based on what you've heard so far
are you interested in joining the
program
and this is just our survey to
understand whether this we're we're
meeting your needs out there you're not
going to get contacted whether you say
yes or no either way this is this is
just us uh understanding where we've
made a clear case for the for why this
program might fit your needs
and just to be clear we will be sending
you a follow-up email that's going to
have information including a link to
this recording and your way to claim the
uh the discounts uh
should expect to find that email from us
but I'll share this in about 60 60 40
split
so I will
um
in in Stuart it's interesting to see
that I want to let people know if if
this is a program for you I'd love for
you to stick in the chat window why what
what a concern you might have is why is
there something that this doesn't
address is this something that that you
don't have confidence in you took the
time out of your schedule to come and
listen to us today we're not meeting
your needs we'd love to know if there's
something we can do to make this program
more attractive to to others like you
yeah
so to enroll for those of you in the
sixty percent uh you email us at ask us
at simplylearn.net I will put that
into the chat
um
and
see that
and we will
verify the very few requirements of
or high school diploma
any work history you want us to consider
there may be some questions about your
interest and aptitude for the field
and that will
let us know if you're
committed to taking the program
succeeding in it there's the email
address and
then we'll offer you the uh
emailed
offer of enrollment which point you join
the program the next cohort
is
induction session
which is actually I I have it listed
here is June 4th 2022 I'm not sure why
that is uh the induction session is
actually next week
and
you can start classes August 28th 2023
so it should say I think July 14th let
me made an editing error on this slide
we say hurry because
we have to limit the number of people in
each cohort so if you don't sign up
quickly for the cohort starting with
August classes
you will probably have to wait until a
future cohort
you have about 25 to 30 seats available
in each cohort so the the instructors
can provide sufficient time and
attention to each individual
that's a that's by Design right Rick
yeah absolutely we want to make sure
we're tailoring the material we're
taking one of the costs we want to keep
the class sizes small because you know
that creates a Better Learning
environment so we do limit the number of
people in each class so we had a huge
response we wouldn't necessarily put
everybody in some people we'd take
people in order so if you're interested
if you think this is a good Mark do that
if you want to try it if you say you
know I'm not sure maybe I'm scared this
is going to be too much or it's not
going to fit me or I'm not going to like
it my suggestion is
get on a payment plan enroll if you if
you end up deciding it's not for you
you're going to get a full refund for
for all of your all of your commitments
so we don't want anybody we're not
trying to talk anybody into something if
this fits you if this meets your needs
great if you if you get into the program
and finally it's not
um we're not interested in your money we
want you to back out and find buying the
next career panel for yourself
yeah there's a qualification for that in
terms of you know how soon after you
start
but
um yeah definitely do not
um
have to feel like
you shouldn't start it
you should give it a try and
see how well it fits with you and it
does everything that we've
described
today and you should be extremely
pleased and successful
um I'm just pulling up
here
next poll
and for those of you who are interested
uh is this something that you want to do
in
current
uh upcoming cohort in August or is it
something that you want to do further
into the future
we always say that if this is something
that's going to improve your life your
career
your economics it's always worth doing
sooner than later
and I'll leave this open for just
another five seconds
four three two one great question in the
chat are there any other costs for books
or materials no all of that is concluded
in the program so all the materials all
of the access you need access to Amazon
web services access to the Computing
environment are in
the program
costs that's provided through the
learning platform
and I'm sharing the results here 30
percent of you who are interested want
to join immediately
and then
email us at ask us at simply learn.net
but I recommend that all of you do email
us there and ask any questions or find
out about future cohorts or see if you
can stay in touch
and we will help you but I'm going to
also include
into the chat
so I'm going forward here
there we go
I'll put it in the chat the link to the
program course page right now let's talk
about questions and answers
so
um
we've got a just one question in the Q a
but we have a number in the chat so
uh question the Q a mcgar asks if we're
able to put 40 hours a week into the
program would you be able to finish it
in less than six months
Rick how does that work
yeah we have live lectures so you
basically have to kind of be paced out
um also just from a learning perspective
you want to distribute this over time so
um
this is not you know a course you can
complete in a weekend this is a fairly
substantial amount of material so I
would I would really recommend taking
the full six months and to get this
um the industry is not going to change
you know we're not the jobs aren't going
to go away in six months this is a this
is a long-term need out there in
Ministry
okay we have a number of questions that
I see you've been answering along the
way Rick so
um
I want to make sure that
any ones that we want to highlight here
the we have uh see Ortega saying I'm
studying by myself and doing other
courses of self-study
can you make a comment about the you
know how that works for some people and
how other people benefit from live
instruction
yeah I think we all have different
learning styles that's one of the things
that you know we've learned
um some people could watch a video and
pick it up
um some people need that sort of live
session
um so we offer both because I think
different people learn and we even
provide references and other material if
you're the sort of person who learns by
reading an article or looking at a case
study
um so we try to do
lectures reading material
practice you know all of the above
um
um some I know we have some students
that like to listen to the live lecture
and then go back and listen to the
recording afterwards they get a lot on
on a second reading or they go back and
pick up the parts that they were a
little can be confused about
um so
um you could the good thing about
programs you do both it's not like a
live course at a university where it's
there and you're listening and if you
forgot to take notes you've missed it
it's always there and then the other
thing is the instructor's always there
to ask questions you can come back and
say Hey listen I've watched the video
three times I'm still confused about
this aspect can you explain that to me
and and our instructors are happy to
have uh conversations with you upon
conversations or Zoom conversations and
and do that I mean they're all in the
field because they want to teach they
want to share and so
um they enjoy these kind of interactions
it's not a it's not how quickly can I
get through this that this is uh this is
their chance to impact people's lives
and that they appreciate that
uh we have a question from Jeremy about
the difference between data science and
data analytics and can you comment on
the on the relationship between the two
yeah great so they're both very strongly
related and people sometimes start in
data uh analytics and and get into data
science and occasionally they even do it
the other way data analytics is
basically using data to derive insights
and so a typical data analyst comes with
a set of data that's been identified
someplace that may determine how to make
uh use of it data Sciences will be a
little earlier than the chain you'll
think about how to collect data they'll
think about the type of data that might
be out there the type of problems that
can be solved with it so there's a
little bit more math and statistics
involved in data science and they tend
to tend to be kind of focused a little
bit more technically that way so if
you're new to the field my suggestion is
do data science that's that's probably
going to be it or if you don't have a
strong technical background data science
data data I'm sorry data analytics is
probably the starting point for you if
you have a degree in math or computer
science you already understand
the basics of data manipulation maybe
you've worked with some of these tools
already in the past then you might
consider our data science bootcam and
you'll get some some more fundamental
treatment and you work a little little
more on the basic theories Etc behind
the data analytic work so that's the
fundamental fundamental difference yeah
and data scientists on one one way of
looking at it is Data scientists build
the tools that data analysts use to
interpret data so absolutely and so
building those tools requires a much
sturdier foundation in math and science
than than a data analyst would typically
have
um we do find people that come out of
school with math and maybe you were
gonna
teach math or be a mathematician
someplace and and maybe you don't see a
job market a lot of those people might
then choose to go into data science and
our data science boot camp and yeah it's
very accessible both programs are
structured the same way as as John
facing but the data science would be for
somebody with a stronger map and physics
background yeah
um we had a question about
um
programs available for people who are
receiving some type of financial
assistance maybe due to unemployment
that type of thing you could ask our
people at ask us at simplylearn.net
about that type of
situation and they may be able to help
you with some of those questions
I'm not aware of what programs there may
or may not be for that
we have and you answered this last
question from Stephen will you be taking
a state examination uh no but if you are
it's an interesting point because in
there are a number of
fields and programs where if you are
working as a for example professional
engineer or other licensed professional
you might need to take a
uh
exam or get continuing education units
this is not one of the programs that
applies for that so right and and just
to be clear on it too there are
certifications you get in specific tools
for example you become you can become
AWS certified right those would be
separate though we don't include those
because many employers don't care about
it so we we're not going to drag the
whole class through something that only
10 or percent of other people might be
interested in but I would say our
program sets you up for a number of
these certifications taking our program
gives you the background then a little
bit of self-study and you you should not
have any trouble passing
these these related certifications
I have just put into the chat the link
to the program home page
and I will put in
just so you can find it more easily
the email address again
that's available take those out of the
chat please
um and
use those and at this point we have just
one last question
um as
Rick said if you would like